oh my god is this a nightclub or see if
it leaves well we are in a bar right
we're inside hello it's a little pirate
rave Tonya what happened to you hey guys
welcome back to Petain mode where we
take the most beautiful games out there
and they come just look like dirt like
mush
my name is Joey and here with me today
is our resident pirate enthusiast Nick
margarita ahoy mateys
and if you have followed GameSpy at all
within the last couple months you
probably have seen Nick on a couple of
see if these sea of thieves things as
it's a it's a game that he is enjoyed
thoroughly does this game the last
couple years or so I love this game lo
so much I've been waiting a long time
for it and I'm gonna be uh anticipating
to see how you can make my beautiful
game look like crap so here on potato
mode we take the most gorgeous looking
games like sea of thieves turn the
graphics to the lowest possible setting
and then try to go even further than
that no don't do it I I'm sorry I have
to it's such a pretty game god this is
the best looking video game honestly I
would say this game does for water kind
of what Finding Nemo did for animated
movies and it's interesting because
there's there's three different seas and
the maps kind of split up with the
four-cross quadrants and all the
different areas that you go to whether
it's the shores of plenty or I know
there's an area where it's more
dangerous those seas will look and act
differently so around where we are here
yet the seas are more green and it's
kind of got this eerie look to it versus
and the shores of plenty it's that
bright blue Caribbean color nice I mean
look at that so we'll make a pit stop
here and then we'll turn the graphics
down as far as we can in the game yeah
we'll see we'll see how that goes all
right so what we're gonna do here is I'm
gonna go into the graphic settings here
and oh boy
for the for the graphic settings they
have their presets known as was it
mythical there's okay just the coop
legendary common and then all the way at
the bottom is curse you know you could
run this on the computer that's over ten
years old easy yeah which is cool that
you can do that yeah so we're gonna set
that to curse and you know what it
really does not take away all that much
from the game I will say that maybe the
water it doesn't look quite as nice like
there aren't as many like a little yeah
yeah so let's go back down to that water
oh the snakes everywhere is God so what
we're gonna do now is I'm gonna bring
the resolution down oh boy
even further we're gone so we have their
native recommended which is 1080p II and
they got 900 P 720 and then you also
have 540 oh boy we're going 5-4 a pretty
low oh okay I will say that you we're
getting some really good frame rates
here and the boat in the water looks
well water looks good don't looks okay
right so let's alright
apparently you can lock the framerate at
either 60 120 90 60 30 but they also
have an option to lock it at 15 oh let's
do that oh god the Bob oh there we go oh
my god I'm gonna get seasick the thing
is is that I feel like I can still play
though like I feel like this I can still
retain it is a little painful water may
not look a thousand percent but it still
looks darn good I may not be smooth but
it's looking sharp it's still looking
good do you think we'd be at a
disadvantage if we ran into another ship
oh definitely I know we have about we're
by our cannon fire handling 15 friends
bang
that's okay I love the animation that
when you usually hit them yeah
you get like a flash of like bone
hitting the metal sword and it at this
rate it's just a it's just a red flash
it's a red dot on though it's just a red
dot all right let's see what the ferry
the dam looks like though I think it
looks pretty good looks a little dirty
if I remember it correctly it was nice
and shiny before it is pretty shiny and
the lighting here is really unique too
I'd say it looks just as fine on the
lower settings as possible which you
know what that means then right I guess
we should do it before we return this is
not good enough so with sea of thieves
it's a very closed off game everything's
in one file that you can't really dig
deep into but fortunately we have
another way of doing this so what I have
here on this screen is the Nvidia
profile inspector and this allows us to
change a lot of different things and the
ones that I'm going to be looking at
right here are texture filtering level
of the level of detail on that oh boy
and there are there are a lot of
different values you can choose and it
will go up to three but I don't want to
do that I want to go even further than
that further than three I want to go up
to 140 or 120 I'm going to import a
profile I already have one made right
here sea of thieves inspector oh wow
load that one up it's successfully and
so that this is a 120 or 240 one of them
either way it's gonna make the game look
real weird let's do it you're gonna
notice a few things missing I'll let you
guess just tell me what they are
Oh God what the heck are we looking at
this was the sea of thieves logo at one
point now it's a box it's just a box for
some reason the entire game is just now
a very neon green oh oh my god is this a
nightclub or see if thieves well we are
in a bar right we're inside hello it's a
little pirate rave
[Music]
Tania what happened to you
should we get drunk oh man me we'll save
that for life all right I don't know if
we should do that right away that's
where the mysterious and PCs are
mysterious right now I'm gonna be honest
he looks way cooler like this and he
usually does looking good nice thanks
George oh my god this is just how the
game looks when you do horrible things
to it feels like we're in Davy Jones's
Locker you know everyone has been saying
that we need a ghost mode in this game
where you where you sail the ferry the
Damned I think we just found it found it
we've made it I mean the the waters just
not there is this still work nope okay
it looks as if someone's vomited on the
screen maybe it'll help if we go up on
the crow's nest okay let's see every
object has this glow to it almost it's
like emitting yeah like the flying
dutchman ship this guy looks okay it
looks like Toy Story skies I would say
let's guide you to a an island but yeah
sure we can use the map well we can just
use a the landmarks right like just like
real pirate yeah a real pipe just see an
island and you go to it you steer
towards it hopefully you don't smash
into it and get real ghost pirates no oh
ah
the bucket is all the way to the left oh
my gosh let's head towards the giant
yellow rock okay well I'm gonna turn
back to 1080 oh we got our frame rate
back right back leave it at Cletus or
whatever Hurst breath of fresh air
honestly also is it daytime or nighttime
I can't tell if that's the Sun or the
moon oh god are you gonna jump in yeah
I'm gonna jump you're out of your mind
so much for that nice-looking water
right I think it's daytime I think oh my
god look at the fish this school of fish
they're just a circle these little blobs
little blob blob
look Oh Taron what was that it's a shark
where I don't know turn to your right
oh there it is all right we're in the
tavern why is this so much it's now this
much bright you know was I think now
it's daytime now it's legitimately
daytime that is scary hey Tina hi Tina
alright so your grog is gonna be oh my
gosh is she a bronze statue oh those
eyes freak me out dude stare into my
soul
yeah let's chug we'll stay in this
corner since we can see both side no
we're going back in gonna sit in the
corner listen to this a little music-box
here
alright we need more we need more Tina
more grog please need more all right
let's try to get some more some more
booze excuse me excuse me more please
yeah one more tanker should get you to
vomit everywhere all right just just
prop ourselves up against the wall
should be good oh hey right here okay oh
here comes you can't see it you can't
see like this it's right there there it
is there it is again some more square
boxes I'm gonna take this one to go one
for the road thanks Tina okay
oh we're outside let's get on the boat
oh no what directions are going you can
find the boat here it's hard to find the
boat when you're drunk in general I
don't know whether we're under the water
or in
whoa wat space Oh are we sobered I sober
up I just jumped into the wall okay
there's our boat right I see that I can
see the mast please make it stop
believin drinking quite a bit in Davy
Jones's Locker threw up in it and
everything so yeah that's it for potato
mode for this episode I think we've done
plenty of damage to sea of thieves for
one episode but if you have know the
game that you'd like to suggest make
sure to leave in the comments below we
might get to him later but for now I
think it's time to say our goodbyes
yeah thanks for having me yeah I'm uh
I'm I'm pleasantly surprised how good
this game looks even when it's broken
all right thank you guys so much for
watching and we'll see you next time on
potato mode got the theory of the dance
is just heaven oh my god anything oh you
broken it completely go towards the
light Joey towards the light is
everywhere this is what happens when you
die in real life this is yeah this is
this is what [ __ ] happens kind of get
lost in this light and you almost think
that you can find your way out but you
just stuck here forever